hello welcome everybody we are going to
playing call of duty black ops 3 zombie
mode alright it worked
great Scot we're family now good job
everyone
now let's make it past around 5 I still
don't know these guns yet like Shiva
does anyone know what kind gun that is
it's a submachine gun or some sort siva
is a single shot isn't it yeah it's a
single shot
I have no idea it's like a I want to say
the Shiva's like that foul he's right
anybody want you just like come up with
millions do this thing you don't get any
takers or words hey get out of here
yeah so you let them tear down the
boards and there's lots of points oh
here's wandering hands that's just
something hookers say it's a catchphrase
anybody wanna dad what uh what's your
characters captors names no I'm gonna
find a way
I'm Lovecraft man then charge the quick
okay so if everyone's quick quick rebuy
before this area that charge that man
that's a stupid bird okay
it's true I'll try to be a dick I just
that's like the I go on I always hoggin
I don't want to kill anybody because I
want to make money cuz I never go down
yeah okay so it's max I'm over here in
this room and it doesn't it's not time
so let's leave until we really need it
Oh next to you next to me
I didn't do that okay another one you
got that kill okay I'm gonna get the
something so the fountain pen is in the
next courtyard in case you were
wondering and curious so we need all of
the summoning keys to do something that
we don't know so something triggers
these stairs back here and we go up
there and there's this altar you
sacrifice them up and I don't know what
it does correct but I'm sure it's cool
but I'll tell you this I'm sure it's
weird as [ __ ] just like the rest of this
shadows of evil really fun nonsense okay
yeah I was there that look everyone
wants money I want money this is a team
effort let me get my money and then you
can escape effort it's the trickle-down
effect when I'm rich I will you know
some of my richness to you who's Jeff
Goldblum right now me Turk oh yeah you
want to open the door for us after this
round I got a new chair I'll do it
some loaded no I don't know the way it's
not me someone else who's that 21 I'm
gay
everybody reload Oh someone who needed
money open that and buy a gun like you
did the richest man alive let me open
this door this game see not only am I
not getting all the farm I need I have
to open the door wait wait wait wait
didn't Rob definitely have more money
there nope how did play now I do okay so
they really like to go this courtyard
let's get out of Koree I would say we do
anybody want to open the footlight
district again where is it open that
team player over there just gonna rock
that revolver the whole day the whole
damn time maybe you're gonna become
swallow your words and I'm gonna laugh
yeah but plan who also is gonna open the
door there nobody else is balling up
spot all right I'm gonna who wants to
let's try to get a crawler this channel
so we can could oh your you already took
a nice round come here and let me shoot
this box give this box quick okay
oh my melee and then go over here you
gotta get the rift door open
where's that past these zombies okay
dammit whoever thought about oh are you
talk with you looking you revive us
quick - yes how many told you to hold
out oh [ __ ] oh my god
alright I got one oh you're just gonna
leave me oh there's Dom ah I got
children
hey I didn't I'm there I still win I saw
did you open the rift door do I leave
this crawler what sure you got that rift
he's crawling
okay so kill this guy cuz he's not Carl
wait oh we already have a crawler
crawler behind ya kill one there can I
open this yeah go for it there's another
runner kill the runner kill that - oh
it's fun out here
dancing in yeah so leave the crawler
civil protector offline crap I need ammo
this is great this is a huge open area
yeah well you have 3000 let's go and
shoot the Roos let's let's not count
money that's not what makes you happy
wanna be pedantic take 2 minutes ago
you're the richest hello and pudendal
what's the first one to get down wasn't
me though I don't think it was it was it
okay what's this green button day maybe
I wouldn't have gotten down if I have
you guys want to call the Train how
about we uh okay that's creepy
who wants to go on a train ride okay
anyone train is that yeah we're
suggesting train train train I don't
make me keep saying train no it's good
listen well look why don't you start the
round and then get on the train
we'll be like well let's explore as much
as we can before the crawler alright it
was get certain right you'll make all
trade wait a minute oh look it it's
Geoff Colvin was character anyway I'm
calling the famous what if you had a
power you could turn us into kids and
then we live in a loft okay all right
I'm calling dress and dance on keyboards
alright you do it yes a little inside
joke it happened to me once I'm talking
about the movie big no oh wait yeah
actually sound familiar to my really
these references are ridiculous I'm
calling the train yeah call the train
the train is moving all right let's get
on all aboard
canal's oh there's different switches
for okay let me shoot it
No
canal's oh it's all just canals that
makes sense make a choice
one star gonna be stuck in here knowing
guy oh whoa no oh can you not come on
alright okay can I learn off first let
me learn more and then press the button
don't you [ __ ] leave me because I
know you're thinking it everybody
everybody learn off I'm not kind of like
them I wanna keep it look let's leave
them on all right go button press the
button he's coming he's coming he's
coming with us
boom we're gonna take him on a ride oh
look he loves it yeah change Rob can we
get you some food skin voice are we
going I'm gonna get on his level
no hey man give me a kiss oh we're at
the canals now sir I'm good map of the
place we're gonna be late let's go there
are three stations is he coming up
behind me you're damn right ov but I
want to get query leashes you want to go
what's through here let's go into the
damn ice on my street this is Hugh
alright new door yeah they're just open
one that's my uncle alright we're not
killing that guy
oh no mystery box down here huh oh sweet
mystery Bobby down there oh yeah there's
if you go to the left there were the way
down past this crawler pit where I met
some sort of separate I have to open up
this gate you want me to do that we're
strange to get to the mystery box oh
wait I don't have enough money who's uh
who's Heather Graham character it's me
but I don't
I need a hundred more dollars we've been
kind of waiting on pickup money
everywhere pick up also I'm a hooker oh
I I got one I'd like to be heard okay
I'm in character
I don't end character until we roll the
credits over this way I don't need their
you said you know what door we have to
go through well no I thought I thought
we'd go through here to open up that
rift that's what I thought all right I
don't know you guys down below does
anyone have a snack don't have any
cookies oh my god here okay this way
come over here give me a kiss Oh feel
you didn't think this through give me a
little kid know what I'm going rogue I'm
about to shoot him so it actually kills
off yeah this game this game down
ridiculous oh hey we're just having fun
we're exploring you should have let me
kill him because then I have enough
money to open that gets enough money
let's go down it's to the left and down
to that box okay yeah yeah so this door
Ridge look a lot wait everybody
let's back up against this door because
if they can't come behind us like that
alright I have enough money am I going
no no yes let's just defend from this
meteor no don't worry about me I always
got your back dude thanks oh you guys
are so cute jealous yeah all right oh
yeah everybody
oh god I'm down no I'm not I said that
prematurely
Terkel I got you huh okay so I'm a
goddamn revolver so do I have your life
[ __ ] that nice nice
all right should we kill the little [ __ ]
round six is dinosaur eat everybody
group I open it or no okay oh yeah Mary
open it let's go get the mystery box up
and at it necessary back this way oh
this way I'll still alive but that's oh
no it's that everybody
stick together we got to go down these
stairs meadow yeah
[ __ ] oh they're ugly look they're comin
up did you become an old man I'm covered
in acid down
Benjamin boy oh [ __ ]
me and you Rob don't yeah yeah yeah I
ran to safety
oh hey go figure whoa there's a there's
one right it's still alive well no
they're a crab didn't we want to keep it
alive
those ones aren't as easy to get laid
around all right all right where we
going you'll get let's get some if it
gives me like a revolver I'm gonna wait
for that person wait how the hell can I
read about the boat what about me
anything even be about Rob over here are
we going back up the stairs wait for
Royal I'd like us to commit to a plan
yeah I'm good I'm good don't worry about
me
Hugh's gonna buy it use the mystery box
yeah it's all right oh crap
there's Maximo get that we didn't need
it but alright so I liked having it we
might we think down here
Zulu I think we should be doing
something like leaving oh that's all
right Mike you're appointed leader of
this okay okay
ragtag group of idiots so I'm gonna need
you like make a choice here let's hold
up it though they're jumping that I got
a pretty heavy-duty machine gun that's
not important though what's it it's a
first machine on the better years I
don't care what are we doing let's just
kill them for now let's come back up
these stairs right here they're behind
us - we're gonna die oh yeah Ryan that
one's down hold on hold on I'm crawling
to you guys yeah you're done I know I
can crawl okay I'm gonna make it if you
want to revive that I'm working on I
think we're all right
well I spoke too soon look we could go
back to train oh you want to ride the
train again
kind of yeah let's try the training area
is they just spawned Oh My Love Train
yeah let's go train go up the Train
Canal station yep
I'm getting really familiar with the
train systems where we going on your
spawn from the waterfall right get it
all this morning get in then my camera
bag grenade Mary can you activate over
there I wait wait wait who is to know or
I just ate my own grenade so I got it
revive it a I made a call what's the
best one but it worked in the end all
right so we're good oh there's a gun
right here if you need a bootlegger
bootlegger it's like mm though good you
got you have two dozen I know but I'm
gonna keep it so that somebody can open
doors
I can we go I think 1200 foot I'm gonna
keep the train fare going why we're just
wasting on it we gotta make money make
money money make money money kill
zombies you ride the train kill zombies
right choice do they spawn here now yeah
yeah they kind of boshi I get down here
guys like this is what we're gonna stop
cuz they're already coming down the
stairs they're behind us too we're now
trapped in the stairwell down a baby you
can ah
[Music]
you